what's up guys so if you guys were ever
setting up a triple monitor setup you
guys would notice that on the back up
most graphics cards there's only one
maybe two HDMI ports and the rest are
display ports or DVI ports so as a
result if you guys are setting up triple
monitor setups they're gonna meet a
DisplayPort to HDMI cable if your
monitor doesn't support a display port
cable right so today I have a
DisplayPort to HDMI cable and we're
gonna be jumping right into package and
see what comes with it and seeing how it
performs so let's jump right in so guys
the DisplayPort to HDMI cable comes in a
small bag opens right up
there's covers on both ends and there's
two ties holding it together
once you get the pies off it comes right
off so let's plug this in and see how it
works okay
setup up this cable is very easy he's
plugging DisplayPort end into a graphics
card or motherboard and you plug in the
HDMI cable into your monitor so if you
got that done that it just works to try
out in the box and it's really simple to
do one thing that you guys should be
careful of is that you bind a
DisplayPort to HDMI cable and on HDMI
cable display because those don't work
unless it's bi-directional so make sure
you guys are careful of that when you
guys are shopping around well guys I
hope you guys enjoyed that quick
unboxing of that DisplayPort to HDMI
cable and if you guys are in the market
for cables like these and would like to
see a DVI to HDMI cable then I also have
an unboxing on that on my channel so
make sure to check that out you guys are
interested that's all for now guys so
you guys like this video make sure you
give me a like and if you guys loved and
would like to see more videos just like
this make sure to subscribe
eternal have been notification and until
next time guys bye